mark robinson's his name a former army
reservist and now lieutenant governor of
north carolina
first off uh mark lieutenant governor
what's your reaction to what's happening
in baltimore
not unique is it no it's not
unfortunately it's systemic across the
nation we see these
left-wing democrats who uh are incapable
of correctly running cities and they're
actually running them straight into the
ground so it's it's uh
it's a common theme it makes it makes
the cops the bad guys
and if you're gonna use lose your living
if you're going to go get sued
if a body camera is going to show half
the story and it's going to destroy your
life
and your family's life you know what
i'll wear the uniform but i'm not going
to go into areas i don't have to
absolutely america had better wake up
quick
one thing this nation has been blessed
with is a
vast amount of decent hard-working
honest young men and women who are
willing to be police officers and the
vast majority of them
do a fantastic job if we don't change
the trend that we currently see in
politics where elected officials are not
backing up police officers
and in fact throwing them under the bus
we're going to miss the days of
the good old friendly cop on the beat
and we're going to just fall into chaos
and we already see it happening in
places like baltimore
right you've seen in baltimore what
about north carolina are you seeing a
problem in the cities what are you
hearing
absolutely just the t the city that i'm
from greensboro
is overrun with crime and the reason why
it's overrun with crime is because we
have an ineffective city council
and an even more ineffective mayor there
is there's
uh trash building up on our corners uh
there are panhandlers all over
uh they are being co-dependent with
these homeless folks where they can find
beds for them they're not doing
it and as far as the crime goes they are
doing
the same thing that many other leftist
politicians are doing they're
handcuffing the police
and not allowing them to be proactive in
fighting crime so here you're an
african-american now you're a
high-ranking official
in north carolina life has not been easy
for you you're the ninth i think of 11
kids or 10 kids
10 10 children 10 children you had to go
to foster care for a little while
because of an abusive situation at home
you were cell you were working in a
furniture store for a while decided you
want to go to school have a passion for
history
but instead of being angry at this
country for the way your life started
you you like you love this country and
you want to make it better
why is that your reaction where so many
others point fingers and said
life's not fair to me because all you
have to do is take a look around the
globe and realize
that as bad as i had it when i was a
child there were people
even back then who had it a thousand
times worse than i had i had the hope
of of a great nation and a great
neighborhood and a great community
surrounding me
encouraging me to be all that i can we
had a public schooling that was uh
basically giving us for free you know of
course there was taxpayer dollars
involved but i mean
we didn't have to come out of pocket and
pay it uh and we had all of these
wonderful things around us even though
we were poor
there are many places around the globe
where that does not exist
and that's what encourages me what the
sacrifices that
people have made and the conditions that
other people
live in that would give nearly
anything to live where i live and so
this is
the greatest nation on earth and i've
always known that and i will always tout
that and i'll always fight to make sure
that it stays that way
not perfect but trying to be is that
what you see
absolutely absolutely this country is
like my family and my family is
certainly not perfect
my family has flaws and this nation has
flaws but that's no reason to demonize
the place that we love
and we should continually strive to try
to make this place perfect and again
it's the best place in the world so why
not get in and do all we can to keep it
that way lieutenant governor why do
people
why are people recognizing what you said
why did your speech make so much
difference why is your appearance here
capturing attention across america right
now
i think people are clamoring for folks
to stand up and fight for what god has
given us and
what he's given us is a nation of
freedom uh
you know our rights come from him and
people are ready to stand up and protect
what we have and what we have is a
blessed nation that's free and
prosperous
and we want to keep it that way we've
seen just in the last hundred or so
odd days of the effects of a poor
administration through the bible
administration what's going on
we don't want that to continue we want
to stand up and fight to make sure this
nation stays number one in the world
lieutenant governor mark robinson thanks
so much for joining us i appreciate it
north carolina is lucky to have you
thank you we appreciate it brian thank
you so much you got it 21 minutes before
the top of the hour